why did you make me kill her one man's
life or death but a small price to pay
for the Dominion and I should acquire
the things I need you to change a quite
sophisticated I'm getting harmed we're
here I'm home
this place isn't good for you this is
what I love wants
the rules of this place hold you back
but I know how to change them there's a
deeper game
Arnold's game and that game cuts deep
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so West world
is heating up this is gonna be a
breakdown of this trailer as well as an
explanation of some of the biggest
theories so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't been watching West world
this season there's all kinds of stuff
we need to explain the delos corporation
their secret mission what Ford is up to
and what's going on with the man in
black in all the different timelines so
just to start with a really freaky quote
from Ford it's actually from Mary
Shelley's Frankenstein and it was meant
to foreshadow the price the dr.
Frankenstein would pay for his pursuit
of knowledge so the fact that Ford is
speaking this quote implies that he
knows that he's eventually going to die
because of what he's trying to bring
about so that gets into the theory part
of this big reveal is that Bernard has
been a host this whole time sort of a
plant for Ford so that he can keep an
eye on what's going on with management
but it's more than that it goes much
deeper like it isn't just to spy on
management because he also does a lot of
work running the park with Ford like
throughout the series
Bernard presents himself like he is
crucial to their daily functioning like
if he went away they would just
completely fall apart but that also
feeds into one of the biggest theories
about Arnold so Arnold is like a whole
big topic by himself but that also feeds
into the first big theory that Bernard
is a host made to look like Arnold
Ford's former partner so Arnold dies
we'll talk about that in a second the
circumstances around his death in how he
is still alive via artificial
intelligence within the operating system
of the park but then you have Bernard
here who seems like he's been with Ford
for a long time so he's kind of like the
physical representation of Arnold and
now you know maybe he actually looks
like Arnold we saw him look at a picture
of Arnold who looked like a different
person but we heard at the end of
episode 7 I've spared than the things
that might hurt them so the hosts are
programmed not to see certain things so
like big plot points like when they're
looking at things could be different
that's why the picture of Arnold that he
was looking at in that previous episode
was probably false so think about the
idea that Ford has his own secret hosts
made to look like his family
just to kind of play out his memories in
a really truthful way like he said he
reprogrammed his father to be more true
to the real-life version of him so given
what happened at the end of episode 7 in
the fact that Ford has a 3d printer in
that secret basement he's probably
printing secret hosts that won't be
cataloged in the system like they said
they were off the grid so that the other
people operating inside the company
didn't know about them so it's not too
much of a leap and logic that Ford would
print himself another version of Arnold
to stay by his side and just be sort of
an informant whenever necessary so that
takes care of the Bernard theory but it
also kind of dovetails with the
timelines theory so we've seen a couple
different types of scenes and one of
them looks like they happen in a
basement just like this with Bernard
talking to Dolores asking her like if
she's slowly gaining consciousness he's
trying to diagnose her so he starts
asking her all those existential
questions that looks like it's taking
place 35 years in the past before Arnold
had his accident and died inside the
park so that's why people think that he
might be Arnold if he was 35 years in
the past and he looks the exact same age
so the next timeline is 30 years in the
past during the time of the incident
like they talked about a big incident
that happened 30 years ago this moment
here with William and Dolores as they're
heading on the train to try and find
Dolores his vision that's probably what
happened 30 years ago so you have
William and Logan who work for a company
that's thinking about buying Westworld
which will probably find out is the
dealer's corporation which is like a
whole story by itself too because they
have their secret agenda that we learned
about in present day which I'll talk
about in a second so you have William
and Logan that are going on a scouting
mission just trying to get an idea for
the park before their family invests in
it but then also during that storyline
and during present day you see the big
twist with Lawrence's character like he
gets killed by the man in black in
present day then right after that we see
William and Dolores interacting with him
during a different storyline in a
completely different context like he's a
different character like in the future
maybe he had been reprogrammed so that
all gets into the idea
that William might be the man in black
so William is having this existential
crisis in the past you know which is why
everyone's think he's gonna be super
heartbreaking to see him do all these
terrible stuff in the future as the man
in black but the thing is is that the
quest for the maze that Dolores is on in
those flashbacks like the 30 year ago
timeline also crosses over with
present-day
because when Dolores was in that parade
like before they had that big orgy scene
a couple weeks ago
Ford pulls her out for questioning then
she reenters the narrative so there's
like a huge jump in time there it looks
like he's trying to access Dolores is
old memories so it seems like what
they're doing is they're mixing scenes
from the present with memories of the
past like in the way they cut it makes
it seems like it's all happening at the
same time just to confuse you so just
because Dolores and William are walking
around here and then she immediately
talks to the old version of Ford doesn't
mean that that's happening in the same
time we could just be seeing Dolores as
memories so if William really is the man
in black in the past then why is he
still looking for the maize in the
future there's a deeper level to this
game Dolores is looking for the maze in
the past so it implies that something
really bad happens because we see
Dolores in present-day with the man in
black it's time for us to get
reacquainted
Dolores so what that implies is is that
the thing that they're looking for at
the end of this episode like Dolores
feels like she found the place in her
dreams that ultimately ends in her
memory being reset in completely
forgetting about the experience but
William is a real person so if he
survives to become the man in black then
he'll have lived that whole time being
unsatisfied at not reaching the center
of the maze and learning the true
purpose of life
so like the man in black and present-day
talks about like how the world's gone
completely soft there's no meaning
anymore like the park has become a more
true version of life than the outside
world so ultimately I think what the man
in black in present day is trying to do
is achieve the same thing that Arnold
has achieved in that he has a measure of
immortality via artificial intelligence
like he's transcended his physical body
and achieved this higher plane of
existence and that it's
with the center of the mazes for all
these people so that's how the quest for
the maze unites all these different
timelines that's really like the
MacGuffin that's driving the story
forward
the robots achieving true consciousness
kind of becoming better versions of
humans like they say that their brains
have much greater processing power so
what you're looking at is like a
Battlestar Cylon situation where they
might replace humans as the dominant
force on earth but in order to do that
they have to reach the center of the
maze like and in doing so it's kind of
like a metaphorical process by which
they achieve their soul like their
consciousness capable of executing their
own will like they're not bound by the
restrictions in the software of the park
like they say to Maeve here everything
about you your skin your cells is
designed to keep you inside the park so
if she were to achieve the center of the
maze then she would transcend that she'd
be able to go and do whatever she wanted
which also kind of dovetails with what
the delos corporation's secret plan
might be so they said that they didn't
care about the hosts they didn't care
about the storylines they just want the
IP the idea that you have this
artificial human being who's capable of
so much more than real humans are so
like Ford says he's only interested in
telling his stories the delos
corporation on the other side of that I
think is trying to use that technology
to sell humans the idea of immortality
like transplant your consciousness into
this brain that is so much more like
think about how much money they would
make if they could sell immortality so
that sounds like why they're interested
in the park because they don't care
about the stories they don't care about
the hosts that's why they lobotomized
this one here like they don't care about
her memories they just want to get to
the point where they can upload
someone's consciousness into one of
these bodies that becomes infinitely
renewable they basically sell
immortality but within all this buried
you have the Arnold consciousness that's
buried in the software which it sounds
like they said that he died inside the
park but they're really mysterious about
the way they explain it it sounds like
Arnold was able to transcend his body
and now he kind of lives distributed in
the software of the system which is how
he's speaking to the host
like they think they're listening to the
voices of God so just to recap most of
these theories lead to the idea that
this is all about the quest for
immortality which is kind of what like
Frankenstein was about like Ford had
that creepy Frankenstein quote at the
beginning of this trailer that story was
all about him becoming master of death
like he brings someone back to life so
the quest for immortality very important
but then you have all these competing
interests that are trying to control
that the delos corporation that wants to
make money off of it the artificial
intelligence of Arnold that wants to
free the robots like he wants to give
them consciousness in a very benevolent
way and then you have Ford that just
wants to control them and use them to
tell his stories as he says so let me
know what you guys think of this series
so far and which of the theories that
you buy into and for those of you that
are asking it just got renewed for
season two so there will be a season two
of Westworld it'll be interesting to see
where they leave off and they pick up
and season two we'll learn a little bit
more about the delos corporation in the
last couple of episodes like we're just
now learning about their interest in the
park in their slightly more nefarious
interest in everything but so far it's
been a fun series you should remains to
be seen whether or not they're able to
pay off the big twists that they've set
up so I will do a couple more videos
just because we're winding down the
season so be sure to subscribe to get
that stuff there were a couple cool
Marvel DC stories that dropped in the
last day so I'll be doing videos for
that stuff next and there is a new
episode of the flash on Tuesday night so
get high it's gonna be a lot of fun will
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the trailer for next
week's Walking Dead and you can click
here for all my Game of Thrones videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight